yes don't welcome to this video or karma
in the house yeah one of the four
frequent opponents may face this stuff
ooh yeah not one of my favorite openings
but it is certainly okay wine
[Music]
and you take hey just recaptures
interesting the 97 I think is more um
more usual we had this position a
certainly nothing special for white but
he has a slight issue that the night is
not ideally plays so we'll see what
happens
it certainly and would prefer to be on
c6 okay yeah one the bishop at force
sleeping like the most most M normal
choice do I allow him to take them I
probably do which retain doesn't look
all that great
[Music]
jab legs position is quite sordid town I
cannot do all that much I don't know
doubling doesn't you threaten anything
okay I have to be a little bit careful
about Bishop to a4 in some situations if
there if there is a double loop doubled
on the c5 Bishop a4 something it's not
not currently an issue and now it is
somewhat of an issue okay but I can't
play with c1
[Music]
and 95 now might be an option
in general on the only thing that I can
maybe play for it to be a little bit
quicker on the C file maybe he wants to
play the should be a neat
it should be 8 and then f6 is quite
weakening I don't know there is really
an issue
hmm cat stuff to really come up with the
with a plan with a real clan this one I
don't know what this does camp that is
at least I'm sort active f6n is always
Bishop age 3 yeah this is a thought
could be maybe a little bit of an
advantage
Bishop f1 now trying to play on the C
file it's it's probably just equal 94 I
[Music]
want to get the Knight to d5 I know that
looks a bit strange but sits nice you
take 95 to just get the knight invasion
it's probably just equal anyway I have
to watch out for the time I've wasted
probably wasted is the right word lots
of time it was the idea get the C file
now however it's difficult
[Music]
a 93 leads nowhere
and Quincy seven days Bishop to d6
unfortunately okay I can go Queen b6 and
still still slight slight pressure
what is the regrouping now for him can I
somehow improve my knight Roxy three
Knights e2 e1 d3 this kind of thing
takes a long time what is he going to do
here group d7 maybe something like that
[Music]
place a simple choice I hope you wanna
head would be one time while a girl
answered can try of course he has more
time on the clock
the position is nothing but maybe they
can do something with my slightly
weakened King position but down at sumo
[Music]
Quincey fly for Queen athlete
[Music]
[Music]
forty-three seconds there's not much
going on really not okay
a queen f3 is a bit annoying
[Music]
hmm what is Queenie five I have no idea
[Music]
quicken c'mere I always have f5
that's not idea really it's probably
that I have a better soon just in time
[Music]
our Quran I'm just in time I didn't
calculate that correctly but it was just
in time can I not to write at the most
problem the biggest problem was that the
time was low as I I just wasted lots of
time yeah this is probably all the way
equal until he not much going on this is
so I thought I could do something that I
would with the fire but really not much
going on
56 I'm a little bit surprised
ok maybe age 65 yes that's an
interesting idea I now have a very good
idea here by the engine my my stuff is
not well placed in that wasn't good yeah
this is probably roughly equal but sir
it's of course a bit easier if I'm with
the time advantage I had f5 at one point
maybe I should have done that
[Music]
some way here check now here that was
not good Jim but okay no much time each
force right now of course H who I just
coverage for I didn't really realize I
can just stay with the queen and nothing
happens and it defends the two
weaknesses no after if six things are
very really critical Queen you fall
stronger now that it's tough to play
catch here we'll just have a draw can
just stay in one c3 and d3 okay guys